i have something for you mike because
i'm a good guy oh do you do you have
something
[Laughter]
it's like that stalmer simpson thing
yeah i don't know why it sounded all
sarcastic yeah
i get it oh i guess everything's wrapped
up and it needs a little package
uh this is um why is she dressed like
her country now
canada she dressed like a love guru
[Laughter]
no mike myers did a more convincing
indian accent sure
uh lily sink team and also better comedy
lily singh takes a lie detector test oh
it's gonna be good get ready this is not
what i googled
this is not the scene from meet the
[ __ ] i'll tell you that
it's getting chunky yeah yeah just put
on the cover weight man did you see that
[ __ ]
close-up yeah oh boy lily
nervous oh my goodness
is your name lily singh yes my name is
lily singh
are you the host of a little late with
lily singh i am the host of a little
late with lily singh
you ready to do this is your show good
yes it is
ah [ __ ] you didn't say there was going
to be a lecture
like ghostbusters
i'm completely is your show funny or not
look uh yeah
no no i i don't know like that sweaty
guy in the beginning
i i don't know and he just quits
10 ready to be very honest with you
in this video but you're not because you
touched your nose
a little bit yes no answers please
my outfit gets wrinkled very easily and
also
um i'm a just naturally very honest
person so i think i'm gonna reveal some
things about myself that are
embarrassing you know who's not an
honest person
somebody who's always [ __ ] telling
you they're naturally an honest person
yeah it's it's like racist it's like
saying it's like somebody who's
constantly telling you i'm not racist
they're probably probably way more
racist than you are
why don't we start with youtube
do you watch other people's youtube
channels
i definitely do not watch people on
youtube no is that true
never occasionally i'll watch my friends
because i
enjoy them as people but for someone who
makes youtube videos i watch
very little youtube so you don't enjoy
the thing
you pump out into the world that's no
very
very weird right just like it's it's
like the pharmaceutical reps that aren't
taking the
vaccine so you don't support the
platform that you're making and living
on
no she's also made claims to uh helping
other small channels so how does she
know
if they're good or not if she's not
watching youtube when does she [ __ ]
ever help the small
when the [ __ ] has this ever helped a
small channel i said make
claims she's a [ __ ] liar try guy
stuff
i have watched some of the try guys
stuff because i would because
contractually i'm obligated to because
they also have an nbc contract
yes exactly that would be the main
reason why i watched it if she said that
do you know how much your stock would go
up in my opinion my opinion of her
it'd be like honestly lily you could
still turn this around
you could if you just snapped and went
full like
ron livingston in office space you would
be
you would end up being a funny and b
would end up winning over all new fans
if she just started going
let me tell you about what they do over
here at nbc she just starts
i was at this party with jake paul and
the atrocious things that he did
she just starts talking about all the
insider youtube stuff he uses a lot of n
words and not with the a like you'd
think
and that's rob gavigan jake paul does
i've heard him consider them friends
do you have a favorite try guy the try
guy oh a sporty try
you notice they cut it because she
couldn't think of any of the games they
caught look at that cut
like was your favorite one you know what
let's go back i see that one again
that's a very good call
watch this cause i would consider them
friends do you have a
favorite try guy the try guy i think i
spent the
she didn't know the names now if that
was my like if somebody were doing that
about me and royce
i would read that and i'd go they
clearly don't they don't
either of us are that that was hey let's
take a moment
and let's tell her the names and then
we're gonna cut to a thing where she's
like oh yeah the one that i
know is the whatever the ching chong
[ __ ] or the
guy or wait he is the guy right
ching chong china all the guys man the
most time with is eugene
and i think we both kind of have the
connection like oh my god
underrepresented
minority robbie tooth her
entire [ __ ] personality
is her sexual status
and that she's brown and a woman also
her entire personality
is based on the fact that the things
that marginalize her her personality
isn't that i'm a comic
right if you were to ask
imagine going to richard pryor and going
you never met the guy's like what are
you he goes i'm a comic
imagine rich regard goes uh actually i'm
a black comic
i know you're black well i think if you
said something like that he'd probably
say something like
[ __ ] i'm dead why are you
talking to me that's true
i've been dead for 10 years that'd be
pretty creepy
[Music]
honey i was up all night talking to the
ghost of richard pryor i don't know why
you know that's going to be a stream
element's name now right i already know
the things that they like
richard pryor's ghost is going to be
telling us
so we have that connection but i think
they're all very sweet
that true yes are you a subscriber to
their channel
can't say with 100 confidence that i'm
subscribed to their channel i feel like
the subscribe function has become just
dust to be honest on youtube because
um well first off the whole reason that
you are
big is because of your subscribers uh
lilly
but i think the reason she's saying that
is i was looking at a little late with
lily's uh
not not her personal youtube i'm talking
about her shows youtube
450 000 subscribers average video views
for videos have been up for a week
10 to 12 000 views something's weird
there like
especially if you're a big youtube star
even if if another big you if
pewdiepie right now let's just pewdiepie
if pewdiepie
right now were to make another channel
where all he did was [ __ ]
i don't know review bathrooms that
across the country
he would [ __ ] get a hundred to two
hundred thousand views of video in the
first day this one had a very clean seat
he's very happy with this one isn't that
isn't that supposed to be marsha's
future channel where he's gonna
review please i wanted to do a blog
about
uh reviewing bathrooms but only for the
purposes of doing drugs in
but now i've gotten older i don't really
do drugs as much anymore i used to do a
lot of drugs every night so you i could
review a number of bathrooms but now
hold on then what were you what were you
crushing up on break
just my my sense of uh optimism
so you snort optimism now no you're
saying what was i crushing up earlier my
sense of optimism
and then i threw it into the trash
[Music]
[Laughter]
obviously i'm saying this because my
subscribers have not grown so this is
just my defense mechanism
what about the demelios you ever watch
what charlie or
dixie does i only have watched some tick
tocks
from charlie because i know she's like
the queen of tick tock why would you
[Music]
do this to her i don't understand what
the point of this is
it's vanity fair there is no point but
no i get it i mean you would still fight
wouldn't you go okay you know what this
isn't working we're just
she's going to come off really petty and
terrible so why don't we do something
else
but they're literally just strapping her
to a machine and getting you to admit
she doesn't support
anybody she doesn't actually support any
of her so-called friends on the internet
watched half of a video on youtube maybe
we should with james charles
i generally don't find the vlogging
stuff very entertaining to watch myself
that's on me it's i'm sure she's lovely
you know what's funny i vlog
so people probably don't watch me either
i know they don't watch me either
they're not watching her
i can see my views but literally let's
say you were just moving to la now
would you join one of the collab houses
if i was the same
age i am right now and where i am in my
career i'm really out of this so i
really don't know
what's a collab house do i please i
don't know what this is
streamers are going in on properties
and then having like streamer houses
like what is poseidon did you mean
well but yeah but they're generally like
successfully oh you know they're doing
it without the feds rating it within a
week
okay that kind of stuff got it okay
that's what a collab house is i know
tick tock there's some tick tock house
it's terrible i know it's it sounds like
hell like
every time anybody's ever brought up rv
trips or any of these like
multi-streamer events like i always tell
people i'm like that
sounds like hell to me like being around
100 other youtubers sounds miserable
it sounds terrible what about what i
have an idea i'm going to start a vine
house
i'm gonna bring that back yeah let's
bring vine back let's do it i like it
just really short videos i would join
one of those clubhouses because that
type of content i don't think anything's
wrong with it it just personally doesn't
fulfill me like i think i like more
scripted
film type stuff i'm starting a periscope
house
oh that sounds oh we're gonna be for
periscope [ __ ] it sounds good very
unsuccessful highly unsuccessful we lost
millions
i'm gonna i'm gonna do a bit shoot house
where it's most people going like
didn't [ __ ] upload again what is
wrong with this
website three times i uploaded this
piece of [ __ ] what's going on
there's 27 people in this house with
accounts is anybody getting us live up
on bitchu right now nope
hold on who's going to be in your house
just oh it's just going to be a lie just
stick sex and hammer well
and adam green stick sex and hammer and
adam green that's going to be my house
it's going to be really fun just arguing
with each other
yeah because you never acknowledge it
sticks because you never call it out
sticks
and he's just like oh i'm gonna go
outside and work on the garden
with no shirt on
telling the truth that's the truth i
can't keep up with the youngins they
pick up choreo like this
the 12 year olds have abs i'm like why
how is this happening how
why are you looking at 12 year old's abs
it's a little weird she's watching tick
tock and [ __ ] her bean
tick-tock videos that makes sense that's
where you would see that but see lily i
don't watch tick-tock videos at all
because i'm not a
pedophile you see that how that works
that was literally when tick tock was
blowing up somebody said that they were
like
do you have tick tock and my answer is
no i'm not a pedophile
oh it's royce asked me grace was like do
you have a tick tock like no i'm not a
pedophile
opening i can't compete with that that's
i know my place
do you stay up to date on youtuber drama
i do everything yes that's a yes i don't
need the lie detector
that's a yes that is 100
yes absolutely the machine's gonna start
smoking yeah
anything in my power to avoid hearing
about drama
except for every other day where i cave
and i read all about it on twitter
but i genuinely don't like having that
energy in my life it's like
but you just admitted to doing it every
other day
is the is the lie detector not even
moving because i don't see any lines on
that paper or anything
this is real just just like her show the
lie detector's not even listening
wow the lie detector is like no
can you get can you get footage from
other lie detectors from other weeks
for the love of god this is way more
into it can we get dr
in here or something i guess anybody
literally anybody would be better than
this
dsp [ __ ] at least i never jerked off
on streams
no idea i didn't spend 40 000 on mobile
games
i think the machine's broken it's he's
[ __ ] the battery's just a complete
[ __ ] liar
would you say that posting a breakup
video is a cheap way to get views
i definitely think posting a breakup
video is a cheap way to get views i also
think it's a genius thing and i applaud
everyone that has done it
would you ever post a breakup video
she would have to have a meaningful
loving relationship before that were to
happen so the answer is no
um i don't think i would post a breakup
video mostly because i wouldn't post a
video saying this is the person i'm with
so it wouldn't make any sense
i am a pretty private person but that's
me right now who knows i could
completely change
next year do you think it's hard to get
famous on youtube these days
i would say it is very hard to get
famous on any social media platform
these days because there's so
many people doing it so you're admitting
that the reason you got big was because
there wasn't as much competition
and probably astroturfing her too and
also
i mean let's be fair really that there's
also a lot of
[ __ ] that goes on that that
suppresses people
from getting famous on the internet
would you make a bad video if there were
guaranteed views
she's doing an entire late night show
well that's that's based on that model
can you follow up by asking her when
she's going to make a good video i
thought it would be nah remember that i
saw this one video of hers where she
like did an accent like her family
so good it's really good
right i you know i'm not gonna say it
she's like the michael winslow of late
night comedy but like yeah
you make nothing but you know be funny
if he's like would you make a bad video
yes
oh sorry you didn't finish
yes i would make oh if something i
didn't know there was a
i didn't know there's a qualifier um
i i do cheap stuff sometimes reviews on
my mom
roasting me or like talking about
something that might be a little bit
more tea spilling but
me personally it's just not the type of
content that fulfills me
so if you look at my vlog channel like
this is real real
i do not get a lot of views at all and
it's because my vlog titles are like
boring and my thumbnails are boring and
they're like
no you don't get a lot of views with
your vlog channel it's not because
they're boring or because it's because
no because her actual main channel was
astroturf with all those with all of
those views
and when you went off and did it on your
own and you they stopped it's the moment
you left the [ __ ] nbc you weren't
youtube's little baby anymore
they stopped astroturfing you i mean
forget your vlog channel late night with
lily
you you should if you're as big of a
youtube star
as your numbers suggest then
wouldn't you be trans everyone would
follow you everywhere
you know they wouldn't just go i'm not
going to listen to her vlog
how was your vlog channel and forgive me
for being integrated here but
how is your vlog channel any [ __ ]
different than your normal videos
is there a difference and also why are
we
talk about a waste of a [ __ ] lie
detector promise
literally just ask you about other
youtubers the whole time and then not
even ask spicy questions
like they didn't want at no point did
somebody go have you ever cheated on
your current significant other
or did they tell you to play up the buy
thing so you get better views for your
new late night show that's the first
thing i would ask
whatever look we we're we're already
running over and i'm not gonna [ __ ]
waste more time on the stupid
today